die erste Frage vielleicht an sie
Pistorius der neue Verteidigungsminister
war gestern in Kiew wie fanden sie die
Ankündigung von mehr als 100
Kampfpanzern ich fand das gut er macht
jetzt auch wenn wir zur Position sind
finde ich dass er seinen Job bisher gut
macht klare Kommunikation jetzt auch
noch mal die Aussage im Interview mit
Paul ronsheimer zu sagen ja die Ukraine
muss den Krieg gewinnen er zieht sich
nicht zurück das Kanzleramt hat die
nicht erlaubt irgendetwas zu sagen
sondern er hat eine klare Haltung und
jetzt muss er auch liefern es geht zum
Beispiel darum was passiert eigentlich
mit dem Sondervermögen der Kanzler hat
uns ja gesagt wir müssen schnell handeln
auch im Deutschen Bundestag das Geld zur
Verfügung zu stellen um entsprechend die
Bundeswehr auszurüsten da ist bisher
wenig passiert das muss er jetzt machen
lass uns einmal direkt rein ins Thema
Frau major weil sie heute da sind ich
habe ich habe es eben gesagt und ich
glaube es geht vielen so seit einiger
Zeit dieses ungute Gefühl diese fast
schon hektische Betriebsamkeit die
wieder gerade beobachten hat was zu tun
möglicherweise mit dem Zustand der
ukrainischen Verteidigung kann es sein
dass es in diesem Krieg um die Ukraine
viel viel schlechter steht als wir es
hier gelegentlich so darstellen
ich habe nicht das Gefühl dass wir das
sehr gut darstellen wie es der Ukraine
geht also das Gefühl ist immer die
Erzählung ist immer die kriegen das
irgendwie hin da gibt es diese Hoffnung
und wenn wir sie ausreichend
unterstützen dann werden es schaffen
diese Aggression irgendwie in Schacht zu
halten aber ich habe das Gefühl die Lage
in der Ukraine wenn man mit Leuten
spricht mit Reportern auch spricht die
dort sind
unter anderem mit dem Leben zitierten
Paul ronsheimer spricht dann sagt er da
ist gerade ein eine eine unglaubliche
Traurigkeit über der ganzen Geschichte
weil die Ukraine das Gefühl haben das
könnte schief gehen am Ende etwas woran
wir alle ehrlich gesagt seit längerer
Zeit nicht mehr denken ja ich glaube es
gibt einen ein großes Missverständnis
und zwar es geht nicht nur darum dass
die Ukraine dem aktuellen russischen
Angriff zurückwirft oder den widersteht
sondern das geht darum dass sie die von
Russland besetzten und annektierten
Gebiete wie der befreien kann etwa 14
17% ihres Territoriums das heißt es geht
nicht nur um das widerstehen können
sondern es geht um das aktive befreien
des eigenen Territoriums und der eigenen
Bevölkerung ich sage das noch mal
ausdrücklich weil wir sehen was unter
russischer Besatzung mit der Bevölkerung
passiert von den Kriegsverbrechen den
Folterkellern den Deportierten Kindern
den Zerstörung der Kirchen und Kultur
deswegen nochmal das macht einen
himmelweiten Unterschied zu sagen wir
rüsten euch so aus dass ihr euch
verteidigen könnt
also das verteidigen können und dem wir
übersetzen euch in die Lage dass ihr
euer eigenes Land befreien könnt und
bislang war ein Teil der westlichen
Unterstützung darauf ausgerichtet dass
sie sich verteidigen und zurückwerfen
können aber den Schritt der jetzt
gemacht worden ist den ich sehr gut
finde nämlich die Kampfpanzer die
Schützenpanzer weiterreichende Munition
das kann sie hoffentlich in die Lage
versetzen nicht nur zu widerstehen
sondern auch tatsächlich aktiv Gelände
zurückzuerobern wenn man sich mal
sozusagen die Zahlen anguckt dieser
schwerbali der Zahlen zu kriegen es gibt
viele hunderttausende Opfern
mittlerweile offensichtlich in diesem
Krieg haben sie eine Ahnung wie viele
Menschen Soldaten auf russischer Seite
und auf ukrainischer Seite bis jetzt
gefallen sind kann man das beziffern
also es gibt verschiedene Zahlen von von
der Ukraine von den Geheimdiensten die
alle nicht immer genau die gleichen sind
die meisten gehen von um die 100.000 aus
für beide Seiten einige gehen auf
deutlich gehöre Zahlen in Russland aber
ich kann Ihnen ehrlich gesagt ich kann
in die verschiedenen Zahlen nennen aber
welche davon am vertrauensten erwecken
ist müssen wir uns auch so eine auf so
eine so ein Raum einstellen
und natürlich ich glaube die derzeit
Faktor ist ein sehr wichtiger Russland
spielt auf Zeit das konnten wir in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten sehr gut
sehen das konnte man politisch sehen
weil Putin und auch andere
regungsvertreter dieses das wird ein
längerer Krieg ein längerer Konflikt und
wirklich dass die Bevölkerung auf was
langfristiges eingestellt haben also
politisch wir sehen uns militärisch
durch die Mobilisierung das heißt sie
wollen sich auch dort auf dem langen
Krieg einstellen in der mehr Soldaten
ausgebildet und rekrutiert werden und
wirtschaftlich durch diese Art der
Kriegsindustrie und Kriegsproduktion das
heißt aus russischer Sicht
besteht die Hoffnung dass Russland es
länger durchhält als die Ukraine aber
noch dahinter wir westliche Staaten die
Ukraine braucht die westlichen Staaten
für die wirtschaftliche für die
politische finanzielle und militärische
Unterstützung wenn wir die ukrainischen
Lücken nicht füllen kann sie nicht
durchhalten das heißt russland hofft
dass es länger aushält als wir wenn man
das mal kurz versucht gegenüberzustellen
nochmals muss vorsichtig sein bezahlen
in diesen Tagen aber ich lese das über
60-Jährige Männer in der Ukraine jetzt
rekrutiert werden können Sie das
bestätigen ist das so ich habe das
gehört aber ich
sagen ich kann ich kann die Information
nicht geben wir hatten Herrn Merkel
dieser Tage hier
demokratieforscher
Politikwissenschaftler sagt der Ukraine
gehen gerade die Menschen aus dazu würde
diese Meldung passen höre auf der
anderen Seite von irgendwas geschätzt
zwischen 4 und 500 Kampfpanzern die die
Ukraine noch hat ungefähr 1.000 die die
Russen dort haben und weiteren 4000 die
sie irgendwo in den Tiefen der die
dieses riesigen Landes noch haben das
heißt was ist denn das für ein
gigantisches Ungleichgewicht über das
widersprechen das ist ein gigantisches
Ungleichgewicht aber andererseits kann
man auch sagen dieses gigantische
Ungleichgewicht das gab es am Anfang des
Überfalls dieses Krieges ich weiß und
deshalb finde ich dass wir uns von
diesen von diesen hohen Zahlen nicht
leiten lassen sollten wenn man sich
allein die Soldaten ansieht oder den den
Bereich Personal ansieht hat die Ukraine
schon Streitkräfte eine ganz andere
Motivation als die russischen sie haben
eine komplett andere Ausbildung sie
haben eine andere Medizin
ja verstehe ich aber noch mal was
bewirken dann 100 Panzer wenn du weißt
du hast es mit 1000 gegnerischen Panzern
auf ukrainischem Territorium zu tun und
da warten noch weitere vier bis 5000
irgendwo in der tiefen Russlands und
wenn man dann auch noch hört das
offenbar zum Beispiel die chinesische
Seite da eine ganz andere Rolle spielt
auch da wieder als wir uns hier
gelegentlich so erzählen also tun immer
sehr neutral aber wenn man mit Leuten
spricht die sich mit China sehr intensiv
beschäftigen und es gibt mittlerweile
offenbar ganze Forschung darüber weil
Russland ja auch keine offiziellen
handelszahlen mehr veröffentlich Zeit
beginnt dieses Krieges aber indirekt
kann man natürlich herausfinden was da
passiert die die Halbleiterproduktion
von China nach Russland der Handel mit
Öl von Russland nach China und so weiter
er hat heute gelesen dass die russische
Wirtschaft um gerade mal zweieinhalb bis
dreieinhalb Prozent möglicherweise
eingebrochen ist also ich sag mal Drama
aus russischer Sicht sieht anders aus ja
ich finde man europäische chinesische
Position sehr schön beschreiben mit Pro
russischer Neutralität das heißt nach
außen so zu tun als wäre man neutral
aber eigentlich ist relativ klar dass
sie eigentlich den russischen Ansatz
unterstützen meines Erachtens aber auch
zutiefst irritiert sind das Russland
diesen Krieg aus ihrer Sicht
nicht gewinnen so also ich glaube aus
chinesischer Sicht ist es eine große
Irritation wie der Krieg bislang
verlaufen ist
aber nochmal ich glaube also die Zahlen
muss man auch mit Vorsicht genießen weil
wir von der russischen Seite nicht
wissen wie viel von den Panzern
einsatzfähig sind und wie viel da durch
Korruption und Misswirtschaft gar nicht
zur Verfügung stehen wenn man sich die
ukrainische Seite anguckt ja ukrainische
generalstaatschef hat gesagt ich brauche
300 Kampfpanzer
wenn man sich jetzt die platches also
die Zusagen der westlichen Staaten
ansieht sind wir bei etwa 180 sind nicht
300 aber es ist doch nur beachtliche
Zahl und Sie kommen zu den anderen zu
den zugesagten Schützenpanzern und so
dazu das ist immer noch kein kein
natürlich keinen auch augenhöhen sind
die da wir hören von dieser Offensive
hat die schon begonnen ist die schon ist
die schon im Gange zwei Sachen wann sind
die da die britischen Challenger die
sollen im März einsatzbereit sein die
deutschen zwei A6 im März die die
amerikanischen Abrams wahrscheinlich
erst Ende des Jahres und die etwa 100
alten Leopard 1 Panzer die jetzt erst
wieder aufgemöbelt werden müssen
wahrscheinlich zum Teil auch erst Ende
des Jahres oder beginnen im nächsten
Jahres das heißt ja das muss man sagen
das kommt zu spät aber ich sag's auch
noch mal ausdrücklich es gab sehr viele
Warnungen dass der letzte Herbst keinen
Herbst der verpassten Chancen werden
soll sondern dass man den Herbst auch
sie hier in dieser Sendung sie ja ich
erinnere mich daran
und man hätte diese Zeit nutzen was
haben wir da verpasst die Ausbildung
beispielsweise wenn man jetzt sagt man
braucht zwei bis drei Monate um die um
ukrainischen Streitkräfte an den
leopardkampfpanzern auszubilden hätte
man es beispielsweise auch schon hätte
man diesen Herbst und Winter nutzen
können damit sie jetzt zu Beginn der
Offensive der erwarteten russischen
Offensive einsatzbereit sind
wahrscheinlich Grenzen wir jetzt oder
rennen die ukrainischen Streitkräfte in
dieses Loch rein wo wahrscheinlich die
russische Offensive beginnt und sie die
westliche Ausrüstung noch nicht haben
was wir jetzt sehen ist das Russland
immer wieder kleinere Vorstöße macht
wahrscheinlich auch um die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte und die Reserven einfach
vor sich vor sich her zu treiben damit
sie für eine mögliche spätere Offensive
einfach schon abgenutzt sind also eine
russische oder für eine eigene
ukrainische einfach schon geschwächt
sind und das ist deshalb komme ich immer
wieder auf diesen Zeitfaktor zu sprechen
ich begrüße das ausdrücklich dass die
Schützenpanzer und Kampfpanzer geliefert
werden aber
gerade sagten Moral wir auch das hören
wir immer wieder deswegen finde ich es
toll dass wir heute in der Sache mal ein
bisschen von beiden Seiten auf den Grund
gehen können Herr Thumann ist
dankenswerte Reise aus Moskau zu uns
angereist ich glaube über Istanbul und
so weiter war ziemlich kompliziert man
kommt da nicht mehr so einfach hin und
die Frage ob sie da wohl gelitten sind
wenn sie wieder zurückkommen ist auch
noch mal ganz andere Frage die russische
Seite sie berichten von einer irrenszene
wenige Tage her Wladimir Putin sitzt vor
Frauen vor Müttern die ihre Söhne
verloren haben in diesem völlig
überflüssigen Krieg und sagt was
er hat gesagt eure Söhne die haben das
Ziel in ihrem Leben erreicht andere
sterben durch Autounfälle oder
Alkoholsucht und sie sind im Feld
gefallen das ist das Ziel des Lebens und
das ist letztendlich das was Putin heute
seinem Volk transportiert und anbietet
letztendlich ein Todeskult ein Todeskult
wo die Menschen für ihn an die Front
gehen sollen für seinen persönlichen
kriegen
was im Gazastreifen Jungen
selbstmordaten und das übersetzt jetzt
ins russische orthodoxe die Kirche steht
da ja auch dahinter gemeinsam mit Putin
sondern diesen Todeskult bietet er jetzt
als Vision seinem Volk an sie können sie
nicht vorstellen was für eine Depression
derzeit in Russland herrscht aber wer
glaubt das oder glauben ihm die Leute
das hat er seine Leute noch hinter sich
weil wir und auch da wir sind dann immer
so dabei und sagen na ja die Russen sind
alle nicht motiviert und eigentlich
wollen sie gerne alle abhauen dann lese
ich wieder von menschlichen Wellen die
gerade da einfach ins Feld geschickt
werden zu Hunderten zu Tausenden allein
gestern solle es glaube ich 1000 Tote
Russen gegeben haben das unvorstellbar
an eine an einem einzigen Tag aber der
Nachschub scheint unendlich zu sein
warum ist das so ja das liegt daran dass
man dem kaum ausweichen kann die
Menschen werden halt eben tatsächlich
mobilisiert sie werden zu Hause sie
werden an den Bahnhöfen sie werden an
den Flughäfen gestellt und dann sofort
registriert und ab an die frontiert ja
es ist gewissermaßen wenn man so will
zwangsrekrutierte ich selbst habe
Freunde die in meinem Alter sind
furchtbare Angst um ihre Söhne haben
ihre Söhne ins Ausland geschickt haben
damit sie einfach nicht rekrutiert
werden und man muss einfach sagen dass
in der russischen Bevölkerung eine wohl
wenn wir den Umfragen glauben können und
den kann man nicht so ganz glauben aber
das ist auch so ein bisschen so meine
Erfahrung wenn ich mich mit Leuten
unterhalte eine Mehrheit unterstützt ist
nicht begeistert aber so das muss wohl
sein und das hängt auch sehr stark damit
zu tun das Putin diesen Krieg seinen
Krieg als Kampf um Leben und Tod
Russlands wenn die wir diesen Krieg
verlieren dann gibt es kein Russland
mehr
und dass er das so verkauft so dass dann
viele denken da ist muss wohl so sein
aber anders als 2014 als alle über die
Grillen begeistert waren wir haben die
Krim zurück gibt es heute einfach keine
Begeisterung
ja in der Ukraine geht offenbar die
Kämpfer aus
ja also ich
wenn wir jetzt also auch von den
Unterstützung sprechen wenn man sich die
Umfragen in der Ukraine ansieht sowohl
von ukrainischen Instituten als auch
jetzt die Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz
die eine Umfrage veröffentlicht hat es
gibt eine enorme Unterstützung von der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung diesen Krieg
also die Verteidigung fortzusetzen und
das gesamte Territorium zu befreien also
ich glaube dieses
die die enorme Unterstützung in allen
Landesteilen für den Kurs der Regierung
in die sollten wir nicht unter den Tisch
fallen lassen ich weiß also ich teile
auch darauf hingewiesen der lange
außenpolitischer Berater von Frau Merkel
war aber es geht ja immer um die schiere
Zahl und dieses Reservoiren Menschen da
tun man in Russland ist ist das endlos
also kann Putin sozusagen beliebig ich
auf Leute zurückgreifen ich habe mich
das Gefühl dass dieses Regime wankt um
es mal so zu sagen nein das das war
nicht ich glaube derzeit der relativ
fest im Sattel dafür sorgt auch die
Propaganda die halt eben dann jedes
kleine vorrück Dingen jeden Quadratmeter
der erobert wird als großartigen Sieg
verkauft aber dieses Potenzial von
Menschen ist natürlich derzeit und
Russland ist natürlich auch
dreieinhalb Mal so groß wie die Ukraine
das muss man eben auch sagen sie sind
einfach mehr Menschen und mehr
kampffähige Soldaten können die ins Feld
führen und trotzdem
würde ich sagen ist das Reservoir
deshalb begrenzt weil das die die
Überzeugung der Menschen und die
Begeisterung bzw die die Notwendigkeit
die in der Ukraine als ein Land das eben
tatsächlich um sein Überleben kämpft ist
eine andere als in Russland viele spüren
man erzählt uns das ja die NATO rückt
näher und trotzdem steht der Feind nicht
im eigenen Land und das ist was ganz
ganz anderes oder deshalb ja kann
sicherlich und ich glaube das was
derzeit läuft ist bereits die
Mobilisierung von der wir sprechen er
hat die Ende September ausgerufen
vier Monate sind über vier Monate
vergangen seit hier die hatten genügend
Zeit die Leute auszubilden und das was
wir sehen ankämpfen ist eben schon Teil
des Ganzen was sie halt versuchen ist
einfach die Front für die Ukraine und
deshalb reden sie dann immer wieder von
Kiew von tun so als kämen sie jetzt noch
mal von Norden die Frauen möglichst
breit zu ziehen damit die Ukraine sich
zerstreuen und verdünnen natürlich und
damit sie dann irgendwo durchbrechen
können das ist derzeit die Takt und und
womit hält Putin diese Angst aufrecht
ich habe das vorhin kurz zitiert sie
haben berichtet das sind in Moskau so
verteidigungswelle Gräten ausgehoben
werden
zu Verteidigung dieser Stadt und ich
habe in ihrem Buch gelesen total irre es
gibt neben Washington DC keine andere
Stadt auf der Welt die so gut geschützt
ist wie Moskau das warum ist es nötig
jetzt mit Pickel und Schaufel
irgendwelche Gräben auszuheben ja weil
man die natürlich nicht sieht Moskau
heute in der Tat eben wie Washington DC
diese diese
Luftabwehr Installation überall weil man
die Hauptstadt eben verteidigen wie das
war auch im Kalten Krieg schon so
jenseits aller Abrüstungsverträge das
war immer da nur sehen dass die Leute
nicht weil das ist oben auf den Dächern
jetzt hat man neulich inszeniert dass
man auf ein Gebäude des
Verteidigungsministeriums noch so eine
Flugabwehr Installationen eingerichtet
hat wobei ich mir sofort dachte immer
wenn ihr das nicht schon längst
hingestellt hat was habt ihr gemacht in
den letzten Jahren ja aber das das
Verrückte ist halt eben wirklich diese
Inszenierung des Volks Kriegs wir müssen
jetzt uns auf den letzten Metern
verteidigen die NATO steht vor den Toren
moskauz und deshalb
stellen wir das jetzt überall hin diese
abwehrgeräte und diese Gräben die heben
sie denn in kleineren Provinzstädten auf
Sandsäcke die aufgeschichtet werden also
man tut so als stünde der Feind im Land
ist natürlich überhaupt nicht der Fall
aber das macht man um die Bevölkerung zu
mobilisieren oder bei der Stange zu
halten aber es ist doch irre oder man
also man baut sozusagen ganzen
Hokuspokus auf gibt keinen
ernstzunehmenden Anlass zu glauben dass
irgendwann mal die NATO weiß ich nicht
weil in deiner russischen Stadt steht
und schon gar nicht vor Moskau man macht
das für die eigene Leute man macht das
damit die glauben da draußen gibt es
diesen großen unsichtbaren Feind vor dem
es sich zu verteidigen gibt und das ist
natürlich auch was man aus der NATO seit
vielen Jahren schon macht die NATO wird
einfach aufgeblasen zu halt die bösen
schlechthin
was das funktioniert warum funktioniert
dieses dieses dieser Begriff NATO wir
haben hier in der NATO über die NATO so
oft gesprochen so unvorstellbar je
nachdem wer hier sitzt ist die NATO mal
sozusagen das ultimativ böse oder das
ultimativ gute
warum funktioniert das so warum verfängt
das so dieses triggern mit der NATO
warum eignet sich die NATO so perfekt
dafür
das ist erstens eine kalte
kriegserinnerung da war die NATO
natürlich der Gegner und das kann man
einfach bei der
älteren Generation die sich erinnert
bestens abrufen man sagt NATO und dann
wissen sie dann weiß man gleich dass es
NATO gleich Militarismus gleich
Faschismus gleich Amerika und da kommen
wir dann auf den eigentlichen Kern
Amerika dieses Land was halt schon von
jeher als der Gegner Begriffen wurde und
in Russland natürlich auch bei den
Nationalisten und bei einem Teil der
Staatsbürokratie immer geblieben ist der
Gegner gegen den man den Kalten Krieg
verloren hat zu Unrecht und als Kränkung
wie man das empfunden hat und das kann
man heute eben immer weiter verarbeiten
indem man halt eben auch die NATO dann
identifiziert mit allen möglichen in den
in den Propaganda Sendung wird die NATO
dann mit geheilen identifiziert man
erinnert natürlich immer wieder an die
Kriege die die Amerikaner geöffnet haben
zum Beispiel
der ich war in einer Ausstellung von
hier langer Zeit sehen wir hier gerade
in Abwurf der Hiroshima der der Bomben
auf Hiroshima und Nagasaki durch die
Amerikaner 1945 wurde in dieser
Ausstellung der NATO zugeschrieben die
gab's die waren doch gar nicht gegründet
die gibt es erst seit 49
vielleicht einen eine Ergänzung dazu
das ganze als Konflikt mit dem besten
und der NATO darzustellen in Russland
erklärt natürlich auch warum der Krieg
nicht so erfolgreich läuft wie er
eigentlich gegen so ein kleines
aus russischer Sicht minderwertiges Land
wie die Ukraine laufen müssen das heißt
zu sagen wir sind ja dann Konflikt
Russland ist in einem Konflikt mit der
NATO in Klammern dahinter steht der
ganze Westen die böse USA und noch ganz
viele andere ist natürlich eine viel
größere Bedrohung als sagen zu müssen
wir verlieren gerade gegen die Ukraine
ist richtig und das hilft natürlich auch
zu sagen wir haben einen größeren Feind
ja um was liefern wir den sozusagen für
deren Propaganda Thomann wenn wir jetzt
Panzer liefern und gerade die deutschen
Panzer liefern ich meine war gerade 80
Jahrestag Stalingrad also Panzer und
Stalingrad das funktioniert noch in
Russland ja das funktioniert natürlich
bestens das hat Putin noch
ausgeschlachtete der neulich in einer
Rede sagte jetzt schicken sie schon
wieder Leopard Panzer obwohl die damals
anders hießen ähm aber er hat keiner
gemerkt jedenfalls wichtig ist zu
signalisieren das was hier passiert ist
genau das was im Zweiten Weltkrieg
passiert
Russland ist bedroht in seiner Existenz
ist angegriffen dabei ist natürlich das
Gegenteil richtig hier hat Russland ein
Land überfallen und führt den größten
Landkrieg in Europa seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg als über als das Land das
überfallen hat aber man kann diese
Stereotypen tatsächlich ein einer
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung gut verkaufen
und ich muss selbst gestehen im
Selbsttest gewissermaßen also wenn ich
zwei Tage durch Staatsfernsehen schaue
dann brauche ich ein starkes Getränk und
weiß manchmal selber nicht mehr wo mir
der Kopf steht und muss mich drin denkt
die toxifizieren indem ich halt dann auf
Signal auf telegram auf anderen Kanälen
halt mir tatsächlich anschauen was sonst
in der Welt läuft
weil sie das gerade angesprochen haben
wir hören mal kurz rein in diesen Sound
in dem Fall von Putin selbst
[Musik]
das ist eine dieser klassischen
wolkigen putinischen Drohung
hinter dem was alles mögliche verstehen
kann wenn er sagt ist es bleibt halt bei
Panzertechnik nicht stehen dann kann man
darunter dann natürlich Raketen
verstehen man kann es sich auch
vorschlagen
und das ist die ständige unterschwellige
Drohung mit der er halt eben tatsächlich
uns bearbeitet und versucht in diesem
psychologischen abnutzungskrieg uns
weich zu kriegen die Ukraine weniger
oder gar nicht mehr zu unterstützen weil
wir vorhin Drohung womöglich so denkt er
sich das Angst haben Sie persönlich als
jemand der so lange dort in dieser Stadt
lebt ja noch
studiert die Moskau geforscht zum Teil
also sprechen russisch kennen diese
Stadt wirklich gut die Mentalität der
Leute gut
halten Sie das für denkbar wird das dort
diskutiert ich habe mit Gerald Knaus
mich mal länger darüber unterhalten der
auch glaube ich zur Forschungszwecken
irgendwann in Moskau war und der
berichtete wir erschrockener war das
schon vor vor 15 Jahren auf Stehpartys
Russen sich gegenseitig versichert haben
dass sie die einzige Macht sein die
jederzeit in der Lage sein New York von
Moskau aus zu zerstören sei kein Problem
das war damals sozusagen diese diese
Allmachtsfantasie deswegen halten Sie
das für denkbar oder ist das wie wie ihr
Mann immer sagt ist das eigentlich nur
dieses Spiel mit der Angst das vor allen
Dingen bei den Deutschen unglaublich gut
verfängt und funktioniert
ich glaube es hat eine Doppelfunktion es
soll tatsächlich uns Angst machen und es
soll die Russen rückversichern wir
können das wir sind
allmächtig die Frage ist würden sie es
tun ich glaube derzeit ist diese
implizit oder explizit nukleare Drohung
eine im wesentlichen politische
sie soll bestimmte Handlungen
triggern oder sie soll Handlungen
verhindern etwa dass wir Panzer liefern
also vor in diese Diskussion bei uns ist
ja eben auch immer wieder diese
nukleardrung erfolgt
wann könnte sie real werden ich könnte
mir das wird nicht wie ich glaube von
den Ereignissen in der Ukraine abhängen
sondern das wird abhängen davon was in
Moskau mit Putin und seiner Macht die
alles für ihn zählen davon wird es
abhängen das heißt wenn er sich
persönlich bedroht fühlt wenn er glaubt
jetzt könnte meine Regime tatsächlich
ins Wanken geraten denn könnte er sich
in einer bestimmten Situation das
vorlegen und ich halte ihnen als
jemanden der tatsächlich diesen Überfall
auf die Ukraine diesen großen Landkrieg
angefangen hat zur Überraschung seiner
eigenen Bevölkerung und seine eigenen
Generalität ich halte ihn für einen äh
der im Notfall eben auch so eine Waffe
einsetzen könnte
wenigstens als Gefechtsfeld Waffe in der
Ukraine um bestimmte Wirkung zu erzielen
aber dafür muss er persönlich glaube ich
in Moskau sich bedroht fühlen das ist
für ihn das entscheidende entscheidende
Maßnahmen würde das auch gibt seit
langer Zeit eigentlich seit Beginn
dieses Krieges immer wieder dieses
Raunen dass das eine der Gründe sei
warum jemand wie Olaf Scholz so zögert
so vorsichtig ist weil er genau damit
konfrontiert worden sei von Wladimir
Putin dem sagte pass auf wir können auch
ganz anders halten Sie das für denkbar
das war es der Kanzler alleine ich
glaube zu dem was jedem sagten gibt es
ja eine Verbindung das nämlich die
regime-sicherheit in Moskau zu großen
Teilen daran hängt wie der Krieg in der
Ukraine sich weiterentwickelt deshalb ja
ich stimme Ihnen zu das geht im
Endeffekt um die regime-sicherheit aber
die wird am meisten unterminiert wenn
Russland diesen Krieg in der Ukraine
verliert zu den nuklearen
es kommt darauf an wie lange es geht ich
glaube derzeit hätte Putin tatsächlich
die Möglichkeit auf den Knopf zu drücken
und zu sagen
es ist vorbei wir bleiben in diesem
Positionen wir haben einiges erreicht
die Propaganda würde das hübsch
verpacken und ein Großteil der Russen
würde sagen puh
noch mal gut gegangen gut dass es jetzt
vorbei geht also das heißt sie sagen
aber ja Entschuldigung wenn es länger
und länger dauert in diesem Land in
diesem abnutzungskrieg dann bin ich mir
auch nicht mehr so sicher und dann
könnten wir in so eine Situation kommen
das interessanter Punkt weil auch
darüber reden wir häufiger mal man
müsste kommt auch häufig von
entsprechender politischer Seite so die
die Feststellung man muss dem was
anbieten man muss jetzt mal verhandeln
da braucht eine gesichtswaren die Lösung
das geht dem Demon was was auch immer
und dann kriegen wir das schon hin sie
sagen die Russen würden das gar nicht
übel nehmen da würde dann sagen okay ich
habe es versucht aber meine Armee hat
leider versagt müsst ihr verstehen und
dann wieder Tagesordnung ja ich glaube
derzeit würde eine Mehrheit in der
Bevölkerung würde damit gehen weil sich
tatsächlich eine Mehrheit
eben in mit diesem Krieg muss ja
identifiziert aber eben nicht begeistert
mitgeben wie bei der Krim das ist der
große Unterschied natürlich würden die
Nation das nationalistische Lager würde
schreien und wir hätten wahrscheinlich
den Führer der Wagner Söldner JEF gehen
und so weiter oder der
Oberhaupt kadirdorf die würden
sicherlich was sagen aber das muss nicht
zwingend von Putin bedeuten das ist
interessant ich glaube einen ein Punkt
also beteiligt zum Teil die Einschätzung
aber ich glaube ein Punkt der für unsere
Debatte wichtig ist dass sowas ja nicht
heißen würde das Putin im Prinzip
verstanden hat dass die Ukraine als
eigenständiges souveränes Land weiter
bestehen kann das wäre also keine Abkehr
von der von der Überzeugung dass die
eigenständige Ukraine eigentlich ein
Fehler der Geschichte ist das ist ja
Putins Ansatz sondern es wäre eigentlich
bloß eine Atempause meiner Einschätzung
nach bis sozusagen das Land die
Wirtschaft das Militär sich erholt haben
die Situation besser ist und er
eigentlich die ursprüngliche diese diese
eigentliche imprallistische Idee aus dem
19 Jahrhundert Ukraine gehört zu
Russland wieder umsetzen kann und das
ist glaube ich für mich der ganz die
ganz wichtige Erklärung dahinter auch
wenn wir von diesem sogenannten
Interessensausgleich reden es geht ja so
wie ich es einschätze Putty nicht darum
sich die vier Gebiete zu schnappen und
zu sagen der Rest der Ukraine mit dem
wollen wir jetzt souverän friedlich
nehmen dann daher Leben sondern er
stellte die Identität und Unabhängigkeit
die Eigenständigkeit der Ukraine an sich
in Frage diese Souveränität will er ja
eigentlich auslöschen das heißt zu
glauben man könnte dem jetzt den Don
Bass geben und dann ist es für Russland
gut es ist ein gefährlicher glaube der
das haben wir auch schon ein paar mal
besprochen der 2014 diese Idee gegeben
Land gegen Frieden hat ja schon nicht
funktioniert eben weil die die Idee
dahinter die die russische Regierung
antreibt immer noch das man kann das
noch mal anders überschwitzt formulieren
und kann sagen solange in Russland
keinen keine Abkehr von dieser Idee gibt
werden wir in Europa in der Region keine
Sicherheit und Stabilität haben und
solange man glaubt ihn an der Macht ist
wird es keine Stabilität und Sicherheit
geben oder also das ist heißt ja im
Ergebnis kommt und das liegt wieder
daran dass natürlich bei der Ukraine wie
auch immer mitgemeint sind weil
natürlich sein ganzer Ansatz ist die
europäische Ordnung zu verändern und
nicht nur in der Ukraine die Ukraine als
Staat auszulöschen sondern eben
tatsächlich die Kontrolle auch über ein
wesentlichen Teil Europas zu bekommen ja
und Grundsatzfragen ne also es ist
eigentlich die Grundsatzfrage wie
starten miteinander umgehen kann der
größere über den kleineren entscheiden
das ist regelbrechen
konsequenzfrei möglich und das trifft
dann auch auf die internationale Ebene
zu gucken ja viele Staaten
sprichwörtlich zu und sagen okay kommt
Russland mit diesem
fundamentalen Regelbruch mit diesem
Krieg führen mit dem Rechte stärkeren
kommen die durch und was heißt das dann
für die Art und Weise wie starten
international miteinander umgehen also
China oder andere